the stryn s fashion label has made
itself over with a new collection and a
new creative director Super Show look
great Lukesh Layla the head of the
company hired Natalia collini would
already helped Hugo Boss Europe it's
faltering women's fashion division
Lukesh Layla worked as a manager in the
automobile industry for a long time now
he's managing a close company if I can
can you fit me I speak up when I like
something but I don't have the last word
here I learn a lot from his I Katrina so
I come around here as often as possible
and let her explain what's going on and
what our current position is and what
she's working on but ultimately I don't
interfere much in production decisions
missions miss ella t bendiga a classic
covered in this vinta the new boss wants
to get this family company back on track
his new idea is to open branches and set
up partnerships in Russia China and the
Middle East he hopes expanding will make
the company prosper wasn't saying this
was good we have to show that we can do
it after our brand is as strong as we
all believe it is when the money will
surely follow you and then we can remain
a family business that's our biggest
able to see this Lukesh Layla is the
grandson of the founding family he faces
a huge task saving the southern german
company at the moment lenez's losing
money
the company has been creating fashions
at their headquarters in the city of nut
Ling and for more than 60 years but
today only prototypes are sown here yeah
we lose production out of Germany a long
time ago at least 30 years ago even then
it was already too expensive to
mass-produce in Germany dynamism until
then we have my father quickly
recognized the situation and said we
have to outsource production to other
countries info log on only 200 employees
are left in Germany and Bella has
already had to lay off some of them the
company wants to attract international
attention with its new collection the
creative director has a free hand in
designing the muggins Austin when you
feel it it seems very dry on your skin
but Pleasant and flowing that's recent
art mmm the company aims to produce
affordable luxury that's how Manya
relative here we have a normal lining
well I wouldn't have put any lining in
it catches clutch nut there it is let's
go for that father the dress will be
sold in stores for about 500 euros it's
sewn in Eastern Europe call it so Mahama
the traditional collection always means
the time is flying and so you already
know the game whether you have a month
more time or a month less somehow you
manage to meet the deadline I wouldn't
say I worked all day and all night for
weeks but of course we did work a bit
more than usual sons club despite the
company's financial straits it still
doesn't plan to go down market and
produce for the lowest common
denominator in ski through Guillaume you
told our focus is the fantastic woman we
don't care whether she's 28 or 69 what's
important is that she has a certain
understanding of style clarity and
aesthetics aesthetic and mid blinged
does that she's a self confident woman
who likes to be sexy sometimes not over
sex but cool sexy
and who has a sassy wink that's the kind
of woman who fits true nestled in this
city forest and passed evenswood
cisternas good yeah now everything
depends on whether the new team is
successful and Lucas Layla's plan soon
works out only then can the German
luxury label maintain its independence